depuis la destruction du pont de vaux
180 km d'ici au tout début du conflit le
pont de valve a list qui ici à micola
yves est le seul mot qui relie les deux
côtés de la rivière book deuxième plus
longue rivière et d'ukraine avec la
volonté affichée de la russie d'avancer
vers le sud l'importance de ce pot que
l'armée ukrainienne nous a strictement
interdit de filmer pour des raisons de
sécurité l'importance de ce pont sera
crucial pour la suite du conflit
le rôle principal de nicolas yves et de
freiner l'armée russe dans sa
progression vers l'europe
ils n'ont pas eu de succès dans les
premières étapes car nicolas yves est la
plus grande garnison dit m
nous avons beaucoup d'anciens
combattants ici
c'est tous ces gens ont pris des armes
le premier jour
la situation à nicolas yves évoluera en
fonction de la situation dans la région
du donbass
pour l'instant il dit on voit la plus
grande partie de leurs forces
s'ils réussissent toutes ses troupes
seront envoyés à mes collègues
l'armée russe espère toujours s'emparer
de la ville de nicolas est devenu un des
symboles de la résistance ukrainienne
cette région a réussi à stopper
l'avancée des troupes russes plus vers
le sud vers la mer noire et la ville
voisine d'odessa les combats qui se
poursuivent actuellement au niveau de la
région entre nicolas hiver essonne
montre l'importance que revêt cette
région clé aux yeux de l'ukraine et de
la russie